you guys think really really happy on
the dance floor tonight you just exuded
personality how are you feeling out
there good nervous what I was really
nervous all day and basically all week
but then when I as soon as I got out
there I felt calm and I just had so much
fun what is she like as a student the
best I mean a dream student like she's
used to training she knows what focus
determination is all about anything I
asked her to do she's willing to try and
you know she's a joy were you nervous
you didn't seem nervous you were
grinning it seemed like you guys were
having fun well we've worked this
routine so much it just became natural
and the muscle memory kicked in so i was
able to have fun and I wasn't thinking
about the step so much so yeah that the
nerves weren't too bad well what did
Catherine think she was sitting right
there next to them and they'd soon be
having a good time enjoying themselves
yeah Catherine loved it I walked over
after we danced and she said you did so
great i'm proud of you i love you you
know so it's so nice to know that she's
behind me supporting me all the way you
did awesome my awesome how did it feel
where you did you have nerves at all you
didn't see my idea I mean I think we're
all terrified in a student's because
we're all stepping outside our comfort
zone but it had fun how did you get over
the anxiety I didn't I just danced I
just tried to actually you know what we
did as well we'd aimed her we named her
the anxiety part a character we're like
anxiety Annie that's actually not her
thanks daddy Annie at home get awesome
before I let you go Derek we love Julian
I'd we left her with how we shot you
later I love Hamas's you have a lot of
sisters about how she doing Zubrin she's
a wonderful listen I love them both
dearly and it's not really in my
business to talk about them but she's
doing great why you killed a girl I
don't remember anything I gotta remember
you don't remember you just totally like
I got lost you know what's so great you
know when you see children playing and
they just don't care what day it is what
time I forgot and just had fun and just
did the best I could do I knew the steps
and I just said let it go baby let it go
you've been through so much this
your chance to celebrate and I what a
great scene with the church and Carmen
singing she was like welcome everybody
there's like hallelujah it was massive
thing was when I turned when she turned
around she would had this biggest smile
on her face not for me was right there I
was so proud of her how is she is a
student she's great I really like it
yeah I really like Isis funny she's
variant is very stuff for taking so it
means I end up just repeating things are
you hard on yourself yeah because she's
harder on herself than I am on it oh
really why well because I know I
understand how I'm supposed to move but
it doesn't it doesn't really translate
and so I just get frustrated because
feel free and I can just keep repeating
and repeating and repeating and then
he'll repeat it in a different way and I
just I understand it I just can't do it
well how was he as a student how did he
take your instruction he's amazing I
think it's because he's done you know a
lot of different things with athletics
the paddle boarding he's disciplined
focused so he listens to everything I
say and he's actually young he picks
things up very very well so that's easy
for me which I like and you're smart you
know it's important to listen to the
expert over here she knows what she's
doing it is its most important you you
were smooth you were confident and you
seem like you are having a good time yes
there are moments in there where I was
having fun for the most part I was I was
petrified and I went into a little bit
of a blackout really oh yeah it's just
extremely difficult all I do is look at
her and I'm back yeah I noticed said the
same thing she was like I don't really
remember anything that happened yeah if
that's how it went man and then it's
over and it was like such relief I'm
still feeling that I'm feeling are you
did you have fun tonight yeah that fun
tonight okay they were harsh what judges
often
I judges every every judge I've ever had
has been hard you made a funny joke
though about judges and about you want
to get lower numbers right well you know
what i think these judges you know they
they obviously love their art form and i
made it easy for him but not being as
prepared as i could have been
technically and we're remedies at this
week no confident you were ready to go i
could tell during the commercial break
you were you didn't have any nerves did
you yeah you kind of take that and turn
into your goofy side can you make it
more fun you get to the point where you
know what let's go dance yeah are you
intimidated at all being the youngest
contestant ever on dancing with stars I
think I'm actually here to prove that
age is nothing but a number and I mean
it doesn't really matter how old you are
or you come from what you do you can do
it so I think ages it's there but I
don't feel like it's there how did you
get over the nerves because it was your
first time doing this and your first
time in front of the judges and in front
of millions and millions of people well
it's so different to me because I've
never done anything like this before I
mean I did dance at school bell 35 years
ago so I mean it was challenging and I
thought you know what what doesn't kill
you is gonna make you stronger so just
get out there but I did stumble a little
as you know they picked up on this at
all you're kind of on a misstep but you
know what I think it's gonna happen it
is over and we did it we did a great job
I think you got the first one under your
belt exactly most most challenging part
of this this the first first night um
get on that dance floor it's like
butterflies it's like I'm gonna faint
can't breathe said to remind me to
breathe a few times yeah so as I as bad
Dudamel and exhale yeah pretty much so
what are you doing what